hi there today we're looking at
accelerating deep learning by focusing
on the biggest losers by Angela yang at
Elle this paper is pretty simple pretty
short in idea and is a pretty much an
engineering paper so we'll go over this
idea and give it a good look and discuss
advantages disadvantages and so on so
what's the basic idea the basic idea is
the following if you train and roll that
work what do you do
usually you have a training data set
which I represent here each line is a
sample and usually you have the your
network it has a bunch of layers so each
line here is a layer of weights what you
do is you group your training dataset
into mini-batches let's say that's a
mini batch for samples and you pass it
through the network it's called the
forward propagation you then calculate
the loss loss of your forward propagated
signal and then you back propagate this
loss and I went back propagating you
want to back propagate the loss such
that it reaches each of the layers and
it tells each layer how to update itself
so what you want to do is for each layer
you actually need to back prop the loss
once towards the layer below it and once
towards itself in order for the layer
below it to continue the back prop and
for the layer itself to update its
weights so each time you back prop
basically once towards the lower layer
and once towards yourself and that's a
lot of work so you see whatever work you
have passing your samples through the
network here whatever work you have you
basically double the work going back and
that's the core idea of this paper is if
you look at the following
in a traditional training neural network
you'll have some overhead in each
training step some overhead of maybe
putting the
data to the GPU or something like this
then you have a time that you require
for a forward pass and then you have a
big chunk that you require for the
backward pass and you see it's about
double the size of this forward pass and
this paper asks how can we reduce this
backward pass time so what they propose
is the following they propose well if
the backward pass is expensive and we do
it here for each data point in these
mini batches why don't we stop doing
this and only kind of try to select
examples that are important and once we
only have selected the important
examples only those examples get to do
the backward pass thereby let's say if
we can only select one third of the
examples to do the backward pass we can
reduce the amount that's required in the
backward pass the amount of work by one
third or sorry by two thirds and the way
they select the important examples is by
looking at the loss so they basically
say whichever examples have a high loss
this must be the important examples
these are the hard examples and if we
only train on the hard examples or if we
train on the hard examples more then the
the network will learn on these hard
examples faster of course there is an
implication there that if your network
is good on the hard examples it's also
going to be good on the easy examples
that's like the definition of hard and
easy examples of course that's a kind of
a simplifying assumption but so the idea
is only select the hard examples and
owned by how much loss they have and
only then backprop these hard examples
and that's how they can in they can
reduce this by a lot now there's several
intricacies here so the set up time of
course is the same what they do next is
they forward propagate the entire mini
batch here because they
need the loss of each example and then
therefore they need to forward propagate
the entire mini-batch at the end of this
they select the examples with the
highest loss and they only use those in
training now training consists actually
of another forward pass but this one is
much smaller because you only forward
pass the examples that you're actually
training on and then the backward pass
accordingly will also be much much
smaller because now again you have less
samples to to actually train on now the
reason that you even need the second
forward pass is the following when you
do back prop you can't simply start with
a signal back here and then back prop
that through the network that doesn't
work
usually with most network architectures
namely what you need to do is actually
while your forward pass you need to
remember information at each layer a
good example of this is the max pull
operation so in max pool what you do is
if maybe a four pixels that are next to
each other and you select one of them
now you need to remember during the
forward pass which one you selected
otherwise the backward pass won't work
you need to know which pixel to backprop
through and that's why at each point you
need to remember information to inform
the backward pass right so that's why
basically you need a second forward pass
with only the examples that you want to
that you want to to train on so you
forward pass once calculate this loss
select the ones with the low with the
high loss then forward pass these again
and then back prop only these examples
that's the main the main gist of it the
this and this exactly what you see here
so forward pass everything then forward
pass those again that have high loss
them back back problem there's a
actually an interesting thing in this
graphic in that you see that this
forward pass here also is shorter than
this for a pass and I assume
that's because this forward pass here
actually needs to do those additional
saving of information while this forward
pass here is simply a forward pass
without intention of backward passing
and you can instruct the deep learning
frameworks to then not remember these
this information all right then they
have a another improvement over their
algorithm called stale selective back
problem so this is called selective
problem they have stale selective back
problem what's still selective back prop
does is it says well we might not always
need this this forward pass right what
we might be able to do is actually so
first we take the entire dataset that's
actually used a different color here
let's use this we take the entire
dataset forward properly through the
network and then save this save into
some database the losses right and then
we use these losses to select the the
individual points here for awhile
all right so um we perform maybe so
maybe this is training here you start
here you you do this loss calculation
and then you run your training until a
couple of epochs and then you say okay
now this information is really outdated
I should really update it and you do
this entire thing again and then you run
training some more until you again stop
and say okay now this information is
stale again thereby you can amortize the
cost of these um four passes so you pass
your entire training set once in awhile
and then use those losses to select the
hard examples and and that's amortized
you can reduce this forward pass that's
used for selecting again by a lot and of
course the paper shows that this doesn't
hurt your performance too much if you
have the stale information right so this
is an entire idea of the algorithm and
the algorithm is detailed here so very
briefly
you have this buffer and you go through
the data you forward pass every example
you for each loss you calculate the
probability that you should retain it so
it's a probabilistic framework it's not
a absolute cutoff if you decide to
choose it probabilistically you append
it to this buffer if this buffer is of a
certain size then you do the back prop
on only on this buffer and this buffer
now only has the high loss examples or
the high loss examples with higher
probability and don't forget within this
backward here there is also an implicit
forward pass and then you clear the
buffer and go on so there are lots of
you see there are lots of forward passes
here to compute the losses and then
every now and then there is a backward
pass whenever the buffer is of certain
size now the probabilistic calculation
of how and when to retain a sample is
very simple you have a deck of recent
losses a history of recent losses you
simply calculates the percentile that a
given loss has in this history and that
percentile will then decide on the
probability if you raise it to a power
and that looks something like this so
what's often used in this paper is this
33% selection that would be the blue
curve and you see the median example
here if you are in the median then you
have about a 33% chance of being
retained if you have a higher loss than
that then your probability rises alright
so the first interesting thing actually
is this graphic here where they show the
what the algorithm deems the hardest and
easiest examples so examples chosen
least frequently and this is the c4 ten
dataset which is images 32 by 32 in
color and you need to classify them into
ten categories and you see the easiest
images the ones least chosen least
frequently are almost all automobiles
and of the automobiles they're almost
all where you
the full car with the wheels and whatnot
like this one this one here so these
these are what the algorithm deems easy
samples and if you look at the horror
samples examples chosen most frequently
by selective back problem its these here
so it's for example bird and bird in
this case it's just kind of a smear
they're just kind of smears on a blue
background
it's understandably that this resolution
is pretty hard to make out that this is
a bird airplane and automobile here you
see this it's a it's only a partial view
of the thing it's not like the the full
car like we saw in the easy picture it's
only partial and this seems to be pretty
hard and it's understandable this cat
here to me it's even unclear if this is
a cat or a a dog and I think dog is also
a category in C 410 so the algorithm is
certainly understandably confused by
this example and deems it a hard example
and here even more you see truck and
this isn't a truck as far as I can make
out these are two humans on the picture
with no truck anywhere visible so this
seems to be a mislabeled example and of
course mislabeled examples are going to
be of high loss to the algorithm this is
the first criticism or thing and the
authors recognize this that if you up
weigh your examples with high loss you
are going to up way all the mislabeled
examples as well and thereby you're
going to train more on the mislabeled
examples and thereby you're going to
possibly degrade your test performance
much more than had you given every
sample the same weight and the author's
address this actually nicely by doing an
experiment and the experiment is what if
we artificially mislabel examples how
much can these algorithms tolerate and
so they often have these
ethics here where they show test error
over time so test error and the x-axis
here is number of back propped images
which is kind of a time dimension in
training these algorithms you see the
blue is a traditional model and the pink
is a selective back prop with a 33%
retain rate so you see the the selective
back prop is much faster in reaching a
low error and this first thing is simply
with one percent of the labels shuffled
so one percent of the images are
mislabeled selectively back prop is
still much faster than the traditional
trajectory if you go to 10 percent
shuffled still you can see selective
back prop is faster reaching a low error
of course the error now generally is
higher but if you go to 20 percent here
what you can see 20 percent shuffled
labels what you can see it starts to and
become clear that these selective back
prop it retains 33% of the hardest
examples right so and 20 percent of the
examples have a wrong label that means
most of what it up ways are wrongly
labeled examples all almost let's say
that there's still a lot of correctly
labeled examples but you see it gets to
a lower but then it gets up again as it
kind of massively over fits on these
wrongly labeled examples because it up
weighs them so much all right
it up ways these because here in still
every example is hard right so these
wrongly labeled examples they'll get
about the same weight as correctly
labeled examples because the network
isn't trained yet but as you go lower it
starts to massively over fit so compared
to the traditional model and it just
reaches this low error that okay is now
corrupted by these wrong labels but
it doesn't it doesn't hurt as much so
that's kind of my first criticism if you
have a lot of noisy labels if or if you
have a lot of mislabeled examples then
this method might actually hurt more
than it helps but the level is
interesting that it can kind of tolerate
10% but it gets kind of into trouble at
20 or so more percent so this is the the
first criticism and that's how the
author's address it I really like this
ablation study that they do here this is
kind of the the meat of the experiments
so what they show here these curves on
the bottom and let's look at this curve
is on the x-axis you actually wall clock
time now so how much time do you need in
order to reach a certain kind of low
error here is test set error you see the
traditional model in blue has a certain
trajectory now calf 18 is a baseline
don't worry about it what we're
interested in is the selective backprop
which is the pink which you can see
outperforms this traditional training
and what we're also interested in is the
stale s be so stale meaning it has this
buffer of information that reduces it's
supposed to reduce the time again and
you see that is even that even more
outperforms the traditional approach you
can also see that the staleness here
apparently doesn't hurt the performance
too much you see the error is fairly
close and it reaches this error in a
much faster time this on C 410 that is a
nice table up here where they show the
speed up to reach a given error so what
they do is they take this error of the
traditional model this test setter and
they ask how fast are these methods in
reaching this error times a constant so
times one point one times one point two
times one point four now of course the
reaching one point
four times the final error is much
easier and thereby but it's also easy
for the traditional model of course so
that's that the catch but that these are
kind of benchmarks they chose to have
faster these models in reaching 1.1 1.2
1.4 times the error of a traditionally
trained model you can see here on C for
10 for example actually let's go to sv h
n as we hn is the easiest of the of the
datasets and it shows them it was clear
so the traditional error is 1.7 percent
and you see that the speed-up is so this
selective back prop is 3.4 times faster
in reaching this one point one times d
the the error of this traditional model
and it's also three point four times
faster reaching one point two times and
it's three point five times faster in
reaching it one point four times the
stale selectively back prop is even
faster so four point three four point
nine five times faster in reaching one
point four times this region one point
four times the error and so what you can
what you can see here is that these
methods really make it faster but also
there's kind of two things two important
things to note in this table first of
all you can see as you go to the right
in the table the speed ups get higher
and what it means is that as you need to
reach as you make the problem easier so
as you need to reach a higher error
which make is as you need to reach a
higher loss value these methods are
there faster what that means is they're
really fast at reaching a somewhat
decent point which is represented here
they're really fast but if they need
them to reach a more and more accurate
performance
themselves get slower and slower so this
this is of course clear because what
you're doing is you're no longer
treating every day to point the same you
are introducing a bias into your
training by only training on the hard
examples so you're introducing a bias
and this bias will give you a speed-up
but also hurt your performance and
thereby if you have to get more and more
accurate you will you will lose much of
that speed up because you need to reduce
that bias at the end that you introduced
so that's the first caveat as you want
to get to a higher and higher
performance these methods will help less
and less because they basically
introduce the bias to gain speed at the
beginning of training or to reach less
accurate points the second thing is as
you look at these problems here so s vhn
1.7 percent error C 410 is a slightly
harder problem 2.9 percent error and C 4
100 is really a harder problem where a
traditional model has 18 percent error
if you look at the speed ups now then
you can see even at this rightmost end
here you have the 3.5 and 5x speed up
here we have a 1.5 2x speed up here over
1.2 1.6 X speed up so as the problems
get harder and as the kind of models get
get um fancier as the classes get more
then the the speed up is much lower and
I believe that's because the the bias
you introduced by reweighing the samples
the bias you introduced will hurt you
much more on a difficult and large
problem with a large network then it
will hurt you on an easy problem alright
easy problem you will find introducing
some bias but if you have a whole
no easy problem then the spice you
introduced will hurt you much more and
thereby this the speed-up that these
methods give you is much much less and
so this means that the performance of
these models is directly ante correlated
with the hardness of the problem and
that tells me it kind of makes it almost
unusable or it goes towards if I look at
the numbers if I look at the numbers
over here and extrapolate that to
something like imagenet it tells me that
these methods are going to be almost
useless on a data set of the size and
complexity as imagenet and the
interesting problems nowadays are very
much in the domain of more hard more
complex problems so the the kind of
usefulness of this method in practice is
something that I wouldn't bet on just
from reading this paper I'm open to be
convinced otherwise but just from
reading this papers it seems like the
harder you make the problem the less
these methods help and that's exactly
not what you want you want exactly the
opposite you want to say oh if I scale
this up it will it'll you know give me
even more of a speed-up and that's going
to be even better but this is the
opposite so and given that they have no
basically no theoretical analysis of how
much this bias hurts you or how you can
still make it kind of good in
expectation how you would need to
correct at the end and so on I would I
would I would first of course attest it
I'm very interested to see tests on
larger more complex problems but from
this I'm a bit skeptical I'm sorry yeah
so they they show I mean they show that
on these dates that it clearly helps it
clearly speeds up the training and
that's of course that's already a good
good thing and they do the required
experiments they do the ablation studies
on these data sets and so on so you can
see here for example on these first
graphic
on all the data sets it clearly goes
down as you introduce the more
sophisticated algorithms but again you
can see on the on the hard data set it
doesn't go down as much all right but
they do discuss this there if they're
really fair to themselves they do risk
us this in their paper of how you know a
practical this is and so on and what
they what else they tried and didn't
work and and that's a I think that it's
a really good paper in itself and it's a
really good investigation alright so
that was it for me have a fun day
bye-bye